ecco
sì nuovissimo e philippe room paura
super motore dal meccanico fatta perché
vuole trasformarsi in una macchina non
lo so svitarsi
presi occorre qualcuno va bene siamo
avventurati avere così quando ma anche
che cos'hai in testa
cosa hai comprato il cappello con il
sisma in the da piatto dei dolci novità
levatela comprare il cappello con il
cibo in testa credibile allora cosa c'è
scritto siamo venuti a prendere la
nostra macchina dal signor rusty ma è
diventato un po pazzo e ciò chiusi
all'interno è invece ha chiuso
all'interno del suo garage della sua
officina
credo proprio di centallo sofficini
dobbiamo aprire le porte usando le
usando i pulsanti per
per passare dobbiamo trovare queste
bottoni allora dove saranno ok presto
dobbiamo scappare da qua se non lui ci
schiaccerà mitico sotto a questa
macchina da piccoli accetterà
che fatto non passata sotto all'olio
della macchina si sai che non bisogna
passare sotto l'occhio della macchina
dai trova i bulls altidore esso allora
qui ho trovato un pulsante interagisce
vediamo successo
ok ora forse possiamo uscire con i punti
restano da capire
sì questa porta qui entriamo
solo staff c'è scritto
global day riuscita di aspirazione e
allora vediamo di qua
ecco
io non lo vedo maria che brutto sembra
tipo 1 rennie che ti insegue e alle mie
scò diventa tutto buio mi ha preso
da youtube
l'olio che lo ha operato
io seguo questo personaggio qua speriamo
che sappia dove sta andando
oggi siamo ad un'uscita ti stavi sberla
successo non sei riuscito
è già sparito bene così e tu dove sei si
racconta questo rais prima tv abbiamo
biasco paolo
l'abito ma
guarda cosa se mister rossi qualche
aiuto sotto che paura io vedo solo il
tuo piatto di cibo lì
che brutto le paste di mandorla e il
calzone il pistacchio
la pasta fillo riviera di pistacchi
tutti i dolci sono perché se sono dei
passi qua qualcuno è salito là sopra il
meccanico con le scarpe sporche d'olio
forse è andata da sopra primo a saltare
qui da questa parte ieri e ancora non ci
siamo stavo proprio per dire ancora non
ci diamo sfracellati che finale
spettacolo
quante volte si straccerà vitale ora
avete lasciato mi piace qui sotto se lo
avete lasciato ancora cliccate mi piace
stories family law aperta io ok ma da un
attimo a fare pipì ciao macché governo è
chiuso in bagno mozzano il bagno
allora qua non c'è niente e questo cose
ha sì questo è quello per i maschi
perché in genere ma non li vediamo mai
questi ovviamente
ispezionando tutte le porte qui c'è un
po trovato un possesso segreto maxi un
gabinetto incantato ma erano vi sembrerà
intanto potrebbe avremo tutte le forze
vediamo grazie è questa la porta ma
sapete normale è qualcosa c'è un'altra
capitato normale
ecco perché c'è un pagliaccio è un
pagliaccio e c'è un altro personaggio il
fratello di scream non mi ricordo chi
era quello comunque abbiamo fatto
descritto il personaggio lo avete visto
se non l'avete vista vi lascio la
casellina africana e alla fine di questo
video vediamo nelle foto
[Musica]
perché dobbiamo sempre passare dalle
poche giando guarda meglio passare dalle
fogne che passare da con gli altri posti
lì che non mi piacciono lo sapete qual è
e quali quelli là dove bisogna evitare
quelle cose marroni bruti
davanti
adesso vediamo come esiste una cella qui
[Applauso]
vediamo vediamo vediamo
ci sono dei
trappole dei rumori sinistri non chiede
vestirle volte a attenzione qui c'è il
vapore come si fa adesso passare questo
vapore
non così
ma forse bisogna saltare sul valore sì
bisogna saltare sopra allora devi
passare quando la parte no no bisogna
evitare come anche i tubi perché sono
escluse verso centri boy mi sono
iscritto andiamo presto che c'è una
lettera
che il rum
attenzione ai vapori tossici qui
qualcuno ha sganciato per talmente tanto
che ho fatto e il gas tossici pensato
cosa
può aver sganciato delle puzzette
guarda tranquilla ci sono solo degli
spintoni che seconda software senato
c'è sempre qualcuno che vuole affettarlo
mente affrettatevi mai per tutta la
dentro farina
no abbiamo affittato no è riuscito a
passare e tu non sappia mobilitare
staffetta non ho o no ascolti
[Musica]
ci sono tre bottoni in questa stanza
ok devi prima di tutte e tre essere
aprire la porta d'uscita
abbiamo visto totti non
è grazie a lui vicino vicino ok ho
premuto prima devo scappare ciao
che cosa abbia mancato uno mi sono fatta
sbriga benetton treviso dove la porta
per scappare ma questa parte da qualche
parte doveva dritto a destra ma non ci
credo che abbiamo fatto punta che si
prendesse mister aspetta adesso ci sono
i laser qui ad ora i laser che bruciano
e perché il tuo cibo si è illuminata
protetta
m'illumino d'immenso quando il cibo
è soltanto un piatto che dove ci ha
fatto più no
ora voglio vedere una strategia che fine
fa il piatto comunque c'è scritto di
prendere tutte le scatole e metterle una
sopra l'altra per riuscire a scappare
ecco vitale il fratellino
quindi scatola poi dove dobbiamo salire
però allora dobbiamo metterle qua ci
credo che sto continuando a strage larbi
continuamente ei laser solito punto
debole ha detto quando dovrei scavalcare
laser con una scatola gigante
premi il bottone per rimuovere i laser
eccolo lì con il bottone l'ho visto che
premino capiremo delattre aspettami sono
sfracellato due passi dal bottone
che ci sono quasi l'ora di quello che si
disattivi nonché da vedere
ma non ci sono disattivati purtroppo
ma compie non svelarvi io inizio a
portare le scatole in
a2
allora ho capito ho trovato una
soluzione forse lei per il pulsante sono
dall'altra parte della stanza
e successo a portata di strano come
perché il pavimento e lava
preparati perché quando arriverai 4 e
molto difensiva è molto attento bisogna
coordinarsi bene che ora che cos'è
questa parte della macchina chiudiamo
don e mi sembra che sono caduta immobili
queste sono delle chiavi a che sono
delle chiavi a cricchetto ma sono caduto
nella mia cricchetto minsk e morbosi le
che aveva sentito questo nome del
bradipo cricchetto di cars
sicché dopo è così che si chiama il
cricchetto che rumore fa di nota
intercetto
ma no un rumore più divertente dai
cricchetto
[Musica]
quanto pensi che questo rumore
prima c'è la parte non so neanche io
come visto che è difficile se non
equilibrio in questi cricchetti
sta diventando sempre più difficile
questi prum ores mano questi puntoni
soprattutto perché è un meccanico a il
pavimento di lavaggio qua sotto e
cricchetti per dieci clienti
ha messo i clienti e vuole
spiaccicarsi in ogni modo come ho fatto
sono allarmi proprio qua sotto pres
dopo melo vitale spiaccicato trovano
prima che il gatto riempa tutta la
stanza e poi moriamo in uno dei cassetti
non è acqua
eccolo dove potevo mettere o grazia si
sta riempendo tutto pretesto dove un
altro
non è che un ciclo ha imparato una
macchina
aiuto meccanica
ti fa aprire 46 dai dai
devo trovare un marmista
aspetto cassetto ce l'ha mangiata a
tappeto il primo capitolo secco no
perché sei morto perché hanno trovato la
marmitta enoteca no
e questo che cos'è una ventola qualcosa
mi dice che ci pare era in area
mettiamolo vitale 10 ore dopo ho trovato
in casa
dai variegati guardiamo mai maria questo
vento
volando tranquillo il cosi detto senza
rendermi conto dei laser che ti tiri
buche bello volare
[Musica]
arrivavo basta
le ruote di fuoco
ok io sono passato in mezzo mia
spiaccicato
aiuto io sono riuscito a passare deve
cantare
possiamo farcela
piano schifo ma le ruote suo passato e
ci credo cha ok a rimanere più trita
possibile
una ruota non è passata una risalita
sopra se la devi salire sul solito
sorriso che saranno i terrazzi si starà
aspettando da qualche parte ci sono
tremila 3000 rampe di scale
stimati e poi arriviamo in un posto che
bello io adoro questo tipo di
sotterranei dei cartelli tipo sono paolo
come abbiamo fatto finire per l'officina
meccanica i sotterranei del castello non
si sa ma non lo sta in effetti un po
strane queste scoprono adesso manca solo
il drago
ma che bella roba un po di vento e 9
a proposito di cose paura se volevo
ringraziarvi perché in tanti se le avete
preso storie paurose il mio libro mi sta
piacendo tantissimo dice rappresentanti
mi volevo ringraziarvi
ringrazio
stato felicissimo che vi piaciuto 80
siamo avete ancora volete per entrare a
far parte maggio prendetela subito qui
camera linking e sfruttare prendete lo
stupito e ma dove è vitale conti non
sono aggiornabili nella lava ma proprio
lì non so perché salto male tanto male
è quasi una trappola no non ci credo
sotto prato indietro si stano dei gas
bisogna aspettare
via
vitale spera cellino io sono rimasto
super indietro io ti vedo per evitare
lo so come ho fatto una strage allarmi
stai molto attento perché qua è molto
facile cadere nella trappola di questo
caso allora quando non passa più
ingrassa e come tale non ci credo che mi
ha raggiunto una gara ha detto che
arriva per primo a prendere il peggio
vincere non c'è problema c'è
fretta
danno che si può fare di tutto da capo a
de paris mago tutto questo cade pure tu
no io ora andrò via rizzi per
amore di straccio lamento
sì il gas di nuovo
dove sei nato un brano lo sai dove ha
superato manovra mai detto ecco perché i
detenuti
si mette dentro babel è detto che chi
arriva prima il belgio è infatti ora sta
andando a prendere il
nome giusto questo
piano
siamo riusciti a uscire dal garage dal
negozio di macchine o
l'ultimo non so perché qua c'è scritto
willis e si chiama miss terrazzi
fortemente chi ha creato il gioco al
ritorno ha chiamato willy e poi ha detto
no non mi piace il mio come nome anche
avviato dove va beh comunque
ci sono in alto e raccontando ad ora
vitale i preferiti vediamo se poi
troviamo il belgio condivido anche a
papà
ok qua abbiamo la super
velocità davvero il trucco e
cercare di non perdere l'equilibrio
non ci credo che non ci
[Musica]
aspetta sono in mezzo ai laser
calci giro dai ceri quati però bensì
raggiunto
dice di provare gli altri di giochi che
campeggio che ci sono state un bel mi
piace se volete che proviamo ad altri
giochi stesso creatore di questo gioco
mister respiriamo
invitare arrivare a tre sono troppo
bravi pubblicità
[Musica]
ciao
il brutto prezzato ieri la sua bocca
fatto che si deve faticare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite buona visione ciao